верховенство права церкви вінні-пуху вин
шпалери шпалери гон мон байден знаю україну
і про петля ти знаємо шпалери виборний
розвести його миколая лютеція мінську
будинків та насті цінні роки він і на може
нікола спати його ти розбавляти водою на
1 в дорозі на обличчі означає поставити з
собою скажімо пізно його позиції можна
рознести ти американський перевозимо але
для вимог різьблених наших федерацій
виїзних у точках України сьогодні звучать
випромінювання україни у практичному цельсію
до судного флангу нато
поліклініки n з отримали штати це
україна плями вливаєшся виступаєте
проти назву на первинний потік 2 які
президенти байден то залевський
розгадаєте я завантажу європейські
енергетичні б спати і т1 головних
результаті візиту зарайського до білого
вдома ви як і був названий від вуличного до
побачення калашникова ндс україни може
повезти ти ще на впоратися означає c
означає ви ікла і аналітики для
енергетичного bespoke аїду пряме без
пайки та бджоли будуть транзиту через те і
твоєї України то ще владна стрима і
росію вид подалі ескалації топ та це
важливо чилі extreme його недузі ми
чудово розмірі чоловік адже в азії
всі первинні шляхи до 2 буду функціоналу
ти вин травня функція на вати на основі
принципі до 3 ми не інтересів ключових
актив на основі європейського
законодавства та таким чином чопа транзит
через нашу газотранспортну систему
buff червону лінію та для ними чини та для
з отриманих штатив рахунку означає на
практиці та
психи благати схожого тобто
мінімальні мають бути
економічно ви правда не
випадково нові тарифи і так далі
третя історія ще Росії газпром будуть
здаватися до маніпуляції по метанню з
туркменським газом ви блохіна х загонах
то тут буду акція акцій орська
політичне будуть санкції як вам це
ясно цифровий кремль я думаю що для
кремля проект первинного потоку c1
приватне та геополітика і можна весь
прив'язки ним і чини і чистими
європейського газового ринку та се бо топ
tawan її намагаються з покус це ще
хоче таяни матч і ну ти
взаємно
пов'язаний є його нас великі мови з
більше неліквідності
німецького газового вахаба дати плюси
німецькому бізнесом там у нас правді
кремль буду нама хати сяду ж твердого
адже його вид буває ася all others
і в крим лера помічу все як ти нас
правді науках байденом вельможа впл його
ти на вимкнули параметри
функціонування первинного потоку
вельможа дозволяти і чин не дозволяє
технічну сертифікацію вид скарбу ти
фактична брутально кожен боїться може
розстебнутий запуск особистого потоку на
особистість може за галина за порожні ти
можеш затихнуть і може поставити
дубовий як травня функціоналу ти первинний
путик може якийсь момент на клас ти
дадуть кови оголення розуму європейську
комісію нас правді це історія ляльки
кремль а ще хоче і звичні новачок
обидва на деколь скоринки і
випадково я буду я до рибки ван і хочеться
вірш окуляри фазі хоч і домагаються party
вати в тему зв крізь негайну з
німецьким бізнесом із німецьким політика
мама так удар одягаються на доступний
німецький ует до сталінграду так
підвішували на вогнище крім прецеденти
звучання на самці ось за раз
масштаб я до чого ящик що плаваю на
запуск
стратифікація з усієї що первинного
потоку 2 такого масштабу було випадково
не допуск
Москви та Росії до
фінансових ринків це таке набряк n'y
a pas touche anya novich його на вигляд
володіючи для буріння для складного
буріння в деці століттях на перуках сетапи
жуйок але це ж енергетичний качок в
ніж у sense раніше і у кремля було два
мига аргументи та аполітичних шпалери всі
хоче ледве видасть буває з енергія
вивчай новикова зараз енергетиків ж
попливла but is брови завищується тільки
ризиковий потенціал сюди енергетики у dc
складно розмова і кмв не можемо ніяк вже
він-то животи вин травня розбавляти встигли
заявити українського то байдена і дати і
про тисячу з отримання штати мати на світ
продовжить це стас його не і в баштовому
законодавства заходимо всередину вираз
транзитну роль України це і gts
засіки збуту і т.д.
застосування кремлем енергетикою в
яскравості політичне оружня проповідь та
гарантій для України про них говорила та
кінцю століття не машини ангела Меркель в 1
година заливки туди заявивши що нерозумності
які самі гарантії будете потрібно не
україні у зв'язку із запуском первинного
потоку два століття поважає складу відразу
мелиш їм пісня візиту задайте колоди
білого будинку чині юридичні гарантії
небудь і замовила меркель замовлень байден
дати їм і після зусу тягнутися дуже читку
видано а ось так сама байда нас гадів і
радіє спиляли заявиш
не будуть я в Росії pdf поета викрали
станина
енергія до оружня у політичні гарантії
і на диск добре конверта вати в неї
особливо акули та проблеми у солідарності
між отриманими штатами євросоюзом та
особливо його в ради не євросоюзу тому
політичні гарантії так вони будуть
треба не алое конвертація з гарантією в
реальність у реальні c проблема для нас
мій бот йому президент України можна
знав так би мовити а ширина різними і
кейсом охоронки можливо треба ставити
сотки ми на сьогодні нижче ми на сьогодні
або їй чистий процес у плані дуже
щодо первинного потоку та c була одна
із ключових завдань за ленська за ленського
на вироки з байденом че вище на тебе
Завдання і часто цей і душі швидкого
побачимо а проти вас доступних ти живий
можливо місяців червона тисячі днів через
вашингтона з берліну скинули з парижем
на сьогодні я стратегія польова в тому
ще зловити рішення у вузькому уколі та
натисли ми я чистив це вузьке привід
наші партнери його немає ви будете наша
позиція може бути і матір'ю і не онука
і престиж і зловити рішення без нас
потім розбавляти з нам і про реалізацію
тих речей c реально проблема топ то
україни вимкненої у прямому анкеті
адже затягли емоції політики та
чиновники в емоціях та розумінні не
онука sti наші позиції оскільки наші
партнери хоче додаватися ціни
що означає не хоче видно з поста
поколювання хоче компромісу компаній
сина шкода вона заходить і в нас з точки
за расу спільна сприймете оскільки наша
зоні schnee політика задньої з але я у
дихотомії cpa до прямого ну вивчай на
авто то душа мережевих транзитних над
хаджей душа сильно б'є по державному
бюджету плюс е почуття гордості оскільки
на сни бути типовою я потім це яка
може бути реакція не євросоюзу на
oxy tesa я вашу була торкання вашингтоні
що ніби ти вічно потоку 2
євросоюз не затікав лани в тому ще проси
я маніпулювала первинним потоком 2
otaq самим технічним потоком один для
критичного євросоюзу жив його рахунок весь
пакет європейського законодавства вас так
званий 3 на 2 1000 пакет повністю
засовувати для Європейського Союзу важливі
в рахунок росія повністю дати вмивалася
всіх європейських провал і наш
національний інтерес також за лірою
автобусі на території України справа
європейський право label шитова в різницю
по річці та митися побуваємо в рамках води
про асоціацію ми дозволялося сама до
європейського суду президента заінська вже
до такої затягнула вину в будинки будете в
досить різкій формі
постав живлення перед байденом про
конкретну дату ступу україни гранату я
ви як дипломат як може
прокоментувати це куб і йому
лінійність в політайте спраги та емоції
президент зелінський як політати травня до
світло ну в районі двох років на підхід
президент байден додому шамай ж 50 може
нас правді з'являтися часто suite та мати
та інших ви таких вислав видаливши потрібно
spooky та діставати та шкарпетки kia знають
душа спокійна даних вставляти в
вашингтоні їх нас правді не спіймають я
пекусь такого образу трохи на кшт
old образи геть і чудово зрозуміло
зелінський хоче результатом а он і каже
вже простягаючись подалі шлях україни
доната виключаючи не пастирську опцію
росії росія , щоб кличу винна
україна та українська державність
дістати нести ким ще в цій матриці ти
ск тому нам говорять досить просту
якумо і реально моїм after'll це ж
сьогоднішню демократію достатньо
хаотичну демократію даним залишилося
teana демократії вони верховенства права
вимийте плити до західних моделей
стабільні столи, а потім говоритимемо
і про подалі терміни он з ногу боці
не хоче dota від і росію і особливо його
частини на європейському полі такому вона
хоче вилазити із теплої ванни із зони
комфорту 1 таки заявок результату
задайте убило убило ми будинку можуть
готувати розсієте можна вчити когось я
каюся з ескалації прем'єром на сході у
краю однозначно можна стати у скільки
мета привіт ден знайка ящик для путіна
дуги можна його на слідку з путін точна
розмел за мої кальцію меча з нашу
голову ще нас правді в ж пастухова вигляд
буваєте в скільки ван і говорити по
життя
життя аспекти bespeco ви і ситуації алое
і все буде прошування дали донато то
ключовими сочі будуть прямої на нас
чи у нас будуть коти без останнього
українців подалі ескалацію, а там
меседжі чи будуть ти на мій кінців і
ключових європейських партнерів чіп не
було проживання у проект отримали штати
за результатом зате chipolino щось знаєте
до треба дати про наймати це 60
мільйонів доларів з вікторією
прокату оборони за крима складено для
протезі російські огрести в китайському суді
вода допоміг для України
кого ти нас сюди допоможуть та його довго
вчитися буде короткий проміжок
його аллена дістати не
це важливо результати з цього алла
темно меншим вихопив іп так нижчих
систем з брів які критично для нас по
три в нього проблемою куточок подалі
постукали збруї і деколь копита нею червона
2 злих на та важливі речі ппц обожнювання 9
ти сам і сьогодні росію а іншим моментом
не довели до нас автобуса з ще елемент
західних технологій за крима
марокканських потро начхати в честі руки
abona у пакеті зв'язки та оружня великих з
бойових завданнях будучи лікарями випусти
мене здається protection та обожнювання дату
вата росія там отриманих штатів
потім серед гір польські партери вам це
на вазі тупцювати
вимкнена острів че
така політика щоб розв'язувати і я
кисть гарячої точки ціни в якому хіба
ні гострих ціни е знак пава фільм до
сьогоднішньої Росії а особі не обожнювання з
відомі піднімати і ставки і давати і
путіну привіт розв'язувати і новіший
конфлікти ну центральній Європі путін
шукаю такі привіт з абсолютно видам вин
піднімаючи ставки та божевілля ще в нього і
обпалена година кирова ти росії випад до
україни це будуть проби прикуті
паспортизації на території
контрольовані нами та на
окупованої території тотальна
паспортизації а потім бажання через
соціально-економічні сплеск сплески
емоцій розділи ти україну реально c
ключові план на російського кіно та
вставати раніше за каїф простих
з броні для про to die та російські
агресії прибрали на ми новому протирала
послом України мені менше не можете
повести те чому не матчі на так
стрима на роги і ціль виразним і болю
чим харчуванням для них і чини поганого vici
і сторічний до світла негайно в завалі
дуже обріжемо залишатися трохи ви його до
посту сподівання збій всі великі поставки
он і дім і і вельми розліталась і
крім того
композиції бундестагу я зі швидко
позиції ангели меркель які поважають
постукати нас було і злості не меч не
медіатора в норманському процесі а
фактично
за те ж можна і віз яка бішма
ефективного спилювання з путіним і до
знову таки путіну прийме для ескалації
особистості в німецькій у йди і не
потребуєте ідею і правильним а
консенсусу в бундестазі не матч і не
за ваші ці рмрс 26 висловити будете
вибору дубль енді ставлю vytorin
відсікайте промивання нове коліт і
підібраний новий канцлер шпалери нового
контракту з кандидатом вночі посада на
ваші думки ми звуть і корисливим українцям
ціну з правді душі важко сказати
на колупати просто тягне їхньому києву
самого оружня я люблю ще ніхто за
реальних кандидатів на зміну позиції
сюди постукали з брів і в творенні
зелених і серед не християнських
демократів та творення соціал-демократів
якщо тобі через причину ще до постачання
оружня там і я не відсікає позиції
ними чини без суті ви з мін хі
аполітичних навколо України диво
постійний у бій змінити а т саме можна
сказати і щодо первинного потоку 2
зараз чекає шість на 15 руки
вправлення ангели меркель мови вам ті
а давалося а проти to offer this
почну і чизів ти позитивну роль івану
vi tigr овал для україни дрібні україни
не байдуже меркель пішла на створи не
нормандського формату кл і в команді
американська делегація та засіки обама
не захотів і продовжу ось
формат за долю з отриманим штативом
обожнюючого цей moment when у поворотному
для всього про йод розмах і побоїв
навколо конфлікту на донбасі та скільки
вин з твоїх європейський кластер і
паралельний американський кластери для
цифровий
меркель дуже багато для нас забув його на
активно наживалось of складні годинник і в
розбір та з путіним an unique ведений
бихов прописати нести російський лист на
Донбасі як і душі брилу кого разу в
скільки з початку вона була сильно йому
вірить і
я поважаю ще меркель забула значний вниз
а до деескалації ситуації 1 година на і
бажання 1 клас ти проблему на
поличках і вишиті спочатку 1 потім дусі
беззаконного baci його на нас правді низ
прийняла результату знижки для Росії.
т
момент як і ким ван і ізар диму не
поливала
загальна роль ангела Меркель і
процесі вигулювання однозначно
позитивно я йду жирну я тягну я дуже
вдячний через ієн кожного нема в
української проблеми через крим вид
буття російської агресії на масці
формат миски біля води цій стороні
контракт контактна група сецесія
суперечивши ж настав чашу коти новий
формат ж висловив ще до нього за
планети москву депо чоловік у вашингтон
мінську будинків та насті ціни в роки війни
не може nicolas проти ти самого
початку baci не реалізації цих та мовляв
негода було фундаментально бідним а
листам засновану на паспортизації на
окупованих територіях пряма
реалізація мінських домовленостей у вона
не мажу його часто suite нормандського
формату ще у нас немажорного формату
на сьогодні так далеко не ефективний
а ось і мені менше у тему форматі ми
можемо розбавляти з путіним розбавляти
віч-на-віч з путіним c означає поставити
з в їжу
у різні позиції зараз тасується
мінського майданчики просто ми злі звістка
обговорювати і харчування практично тому
без знаходить мету мій данчик у мінськ вул
стамбулі там davichi вище мої вісті та
цінно з правді не критично ви також
заявляв і проти зеленського відриву
просто це про різні марокканські
вісник весь на територію краху не
можете сказати чому
оскільки c дадуть вичин dex вимоги
cd дисковий чинних злочинності
і цілком насті для українців і
українця зі списку і я покараю
прообразу розміщення ризикових страйків
політично це дуже складно ціни будуть
сьогодні на завтра та післязавтра
червоним можна розмістити американський
перевозила для вимоги різьблених наших
pd виробів виїзних точках україни для
взаємодій для бабки інформації та баху
тих речах промовах топ топаз тупого буду
ват це куб і суть нести води означають
випромінювання україни у практичному уельсі
дошки дна у фланг у нато і не матчі на
та євросоюз та з отримання штати Америки
в обмін на своє харчування ринку вимагає вигляду
україни реформ топ то до гри за 100
пермінова у брата кривляка sap
за хвости це повного ж не директора
набу і запас почитай про за роги
знайдений процес зборів нових
кривляка і наріжте просто сюди
бура форма з ніг була прекрасна але на а
тут ще й поставити кого і байдена
вашингтоні до нинішньої води в Україні
з мережі відсіку ваня van een африці ви
правда не я ще ви шанують з pillins я
ось і цей розділ там тобто. конкретика
ну я до зв'язку з сам це його зробили києва
і процвітав і і знов таки означаючи
особливо його ваху американських партнерів
сама до
антикорупційних інституцій та додавши
вмивання суднової системи диск вашингтону
і і я поважаю шукаються провалить позов
оскільки c ключова стоячи для того щоб
раз монтажу ти наш тип зовсім не дасть
каналу та демократії у нормальний захист
демократії в їх час президентства
порошенка була практично та сама і
все зуба в'язання україна завищується чому
я проводжає нічого такого ну пам'ятному
це буває оскільки жадібно політична
реальність в Україні не вистачило
реальних провал за право jeunesse їх
права та верховенства права 5 їжу життя та
у порошенка та ленського аланія до
політична реальність не хоче
випускати його жили своїх рук і c і
фундаментальне про ітан і культуру з
галузі демократії так само булава
порошенка так само віленського так само
була по поїді ви хреста не
антикорупційні інституції та й через
буду недавно суднові системи в
політичних цілях ct
проводжаючи нашим партнерам сказати і нам
так ви змінюєтеся так ви маленькі тфп
так у вас є альні годинні шанс на
нато і ес і поки ми граємо is still
політику ми порушуємо й set vector format
c все було звучання вашингтоні йєнна і
на подальшу і я як результат ми були
задавлені ті вашингтон верховенства
права церкви від вінні-пуху вин шпалери шпалери
гнана там вона можна сказати ще sap
china був
використано теж не судову систему
набагато важливіші речі і миша
саме забуті розум одна частина накатати
кульмінація довго начебто затягнемо
видобуто стяг за цей убив готова так як
розвивалася президента залає кодеки
американські змі а ви я крат разу це я
не бачу жадібну кульмінацію я не бачу тут
вони провали вони успіху не за так і не
допоможе я поважаюча робоча пузатим на
душі корислива історія та iso швидко для
владимира зеленського та для українців c
шанс вас останню встиг кататися з
байденом вич у тієї води модної душі
виду автор граничний виду арта
поговорити про скільки байден знаю україну
і заспівати і знаємо шпалери виборний
розвести його миколу не дасть я двома
руками
обожнюю успіху зеленому абсолютно
хіроус clicker мови з літера росії Іван
реально скласти ви заявлялося
результати з цього заявка до вашингтону
закласти крученого ніж тікали
продемонстрована ще в українській
влади я політична воля і реально
правда не успіху рахунку був випробуваний у
ключових промовах і в хату читається
записано в спилили та заяви все харчування
чудова їх агенції право ван і не
реалізовані а келихи за ленським проханням
байдена і c правильно байди може
повезти ще у вас душа бронза мовляв і ним
і так далі там у нас правді є принципу
very chalky не diablo не обозу місцевих
вигляд буваєте імітація ціни означає що у
нас намотати явну цифровізацію cl1 знаючи
краще до сірчаної алеф ключових
критичних для заходу харчування та впш
чого фрагах агенство право реформ
забезпечуючи оборонного сектора мишку
таліга йому поділяються на завдання скіф
поміщений що джо байден прямо запрошення
або 2d кліфф а моя за цих умов ти знайшла
його за умов радикального пресового з
харчування верховенства права та реформи б
стійкого оборонного сектору байдан якобу
дикі політик на методики та душі
харчована україном і моя емоція чи хочеш
чогось історію успіху байден по їжа в
українці тільки спільної вин буде бачатою
ту історію таку історію успіху і на
спілкування я поставлю сюди президентської
initiated українська платформа позитивно
я завжди дати маусі їж і стратегії я
хоч і затихнути і росію вам до ворони
хоча б гуманітарних екологічних танучих
катувати за розкол та харчування
окупованого криму стала проси та ти
йому сильні з точки зору злочинності
ЗМІ по його внутрішньо увагу дуже важливо на
високому рівні та початкова кримська
платформа не зайшла у почетах медіа так
як могла б за і те ік шепні колишнього не
стану від країни був не личить не на
тому і нед мис поділася чому ключ
чи не вийти на Італія Франція токто
ванни я би на ви знаєте не прийняти
участь у телефон і просто
допомагають
акуратно баланс аватарі ви ще безбаїв
ти
канали swiss шматкам mc2 їх вибір ви в
пази сюди нинішня владика їжа допомагати
виразки чайного позиція ви готові так
допомагати і я не бачу всього в тему жадібні
з міцності і обожнює окладу
так і опозиції
ще більше якихось називаєте позиція
собрівці околиці Іван Євгенович
позитивних імпульсів він іммігрує
імпульсів плану shimai будь її образ
мій буде йому ноги не піти імпульсу
національну їжу насті нахи не відлетиш
невігласів вишнею і на магнітиці ви
поважні стиснуті води народного та ck та
нові-нові а
це означає що потрібно по е тануть я
зроблю покоління ось такого фейсбуку
покоління ютьюбу і тик струм і в сошники
вид-во це будує і українець з українцями
які будуть мати паза ти мені емоції і
drive додому буди на віки вимиють та
політичні амбіції
бананом а політичних амбіцій у сейфі
заняття буде їх посад ось я вже був у
п'ять рук з міністром закордонних прав та
я у вічний
реальності шанс в sims кима я проти
фактами не до помахавши
вени та амбіціями літати україну ось
висловить і зникли tokoumono я амбіція
змінити sense отрута проти українська
політика я хочу шифону party vol від вже
близько до європейського зразок і я вірю
мережею реальність можна змінити і буду
насипати його ти незалежна крученого ще для
чого потрібно я душити його хоче навіть
такого відео до вас